[موسيقى]
الاخبار من الجزيره اينما كنتم والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله قال رئيس شعبه
الاستخبارات العسكريه هارون حليف عن الامن
العامله لحزب الاهل اللبناني يقترب من
ارتكاب خطا قد يدفع المنطقه الى حرب كبرى
من جهته قلى وزر الدفاع الاسرائيلي
تخوض حرب استنزاف ضد اسرائيل
بوكلائها القريبين عبر الحدود
في المقابل قال مسؤول ايراني للجزيره ان
اي اعتداء عسكري على المنشات النوويه
سيقابل برد واسع وغير مسبوق واضافنا تقصيب
باليورانيوم يجري عند عتبه 60 في المئه
جاء ذلك بعد يومين من تنفيذ حزب الله
اللبناني مناوره ميدانيه تضمنت محاكاه
لعمليه اسر جنود اسرائيليين واقتحام
مستوطنه اسرائيليه اضافه الى عبور مئات
المقاتلين الحدود واستعراض السراب من
الطائرات المسيره وقصف لمواقع اسرائيليه
وقد لوح انطوني بلينكن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه بمعاقبه من ينتهك الهدنه
الجديده التي ابرمها طرف الصراعي في
السودان
في تركيا اعلنا المرشح والرئاسي السابق
سنان اوغانا انه سيدعم مرشح تحالف الجمهور
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في دوله الاعاده
واكد اوغانا انه لم يدخل في مساومات او
تعهدات خلال اللقاءات مع المرشحين
الرئاسيين
وقال الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان انه لم ولن
يخوض ايام مفاوضات مع سنان اوغان واعربا
عن امله في ان يصوت الشعب التركي له
بكثافه وان يحصل على رقم قياسي من الاصوات
في جوله الاعاده
في المقابل قال مرشح والتحالف الشعب كمالك
الجدار اوغلو انه باتا من الواضحين من يقف
الى صف الوطن ومن يقف الى جانب من يبيعه
واضفنا تحالفه قادم لانقاذ تركيا من
الارهابي ومن اللاجئين بحسب تعبيره
انتهى اجتماع بين الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ورئيس مجلس النواب كيفن في البيت هي
الابيض دون اتفاق يجنب الولايات المتحده
التخلفه عن سداد ديونها قبل نهايه الشهر
الجاري وقال بايدن الى اللقاء مع مكارتي
كان مثمرا واضاف ان التخلف عن السداد ليس
خيارا مطروحا على الطاوله بدوره قلم
كارتيه انه لا تزال هناك خلافات بشان حل
الازمه مضيفا لنا التواصل لارضيه مشتركه
ممكن في نهايه المطاف انما كنتم طبت
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]